you're nominated for entertainer of the
year if you win
you'll beat taylor swift and luke bryan
and tie
mickey gilly and the dixie chicks for
the fastest climb
from a new artist to the top prize did
you know that
i didn't know that i didn't know that
that's pretty cool though
you know what i mean um so man
pressure's on i guess now
i wasn't nervous until now what um
does it what goes through your mind when
you hear
all those names and that that
that you could possibly be you know i
don't know i mean taylor swift's doing
all right
you know she's doing pretty good i hear
yeah you know no that's
it's really cool you know and i think um
you know i never expect to win anything
and
um i think it's it would be an
interesting time to win it
you know it's kind of like well it's
like most days
you know playing video games kind of
like i don't know i don't know
you know but i tried to stay as busy as
i could this year and
i don't know every time i hear the i
turn on the radio i hear your voice
that's good that's good that's a good
thing you know i mean that's a good
thing so we'll see i
i would be thrilled to win yeah okay so
you are performing forever after all
yes another song that has been written
for your wife
how excited are you and like emotional
are you to perform that oh man i'm
excited you know it was nice to
to be up on stage with the with the band
again you know that felt good and
um i don't know about like emotional you
know i don't want to get like weepy
up there you know what i mean because i
still gotta sing so hopefully that
doesn't happen we'll see though
i know garth gets weepy from time to day
he does he gets weepy every now and then
but you know
i don't know i just like i can't if i'm
crying i can't sing you know
is that the key to you know a successful
marriage is writing you know love songs
every now and again
yeah for sure it doesn't hurt you know
it doesn't hurt
you know you could give it a shot even
if it's bad they're still gonna like it
you know i think you know so it makes me
wonder like is it really bad
and now i don't know because it's like
she's not going to be like i hated that
song you heard about me you know
okay good good i'm glad what have you
learned about being a husband
man i've learned a lot you know i've
learned to kind of just go with it
i feel like is the most important thing
yeah you know
like you know you hear happy wife happy
life and you're like oh okay here we go
another guy saying happy wife happy life
kind of thing you know
and now that's i'm that guy now last
year you won both male artists
and album beer what did those wins mean
personally to you
and do you think they had an effect on
your career
i mean i think any time that you you
know win an award on tv is a huge moment
for you you know it's an opportunity for
people to see you and
um so so you know being able to perform
or
win an award is a huge win for anybody
you know especially
somebody who hasn't won those awards
before like myself you know and
and uh album of the year is something
that was always on my bucket list
something i always wanted to win
at least once and so having done that
was was real special and
mail artist was really awesome too you
know um
there's not an award that i could win
that i would be like upset about i
wouldn't be like yeah i can't believe i
won that one you know what i mean
that's like they're all pretty cool you
know yeah you do although you have to
get like dressed up every time to go get
one
right that's true that's true there's no
sweatpants you know what i mean and i've
had a lot of sweatpants this year how
does it feel to put on a suit jacket it
feels good
you know at least these are like you
can't tell they're jeans you know but
they're jeans still so that feels good
yeah absolutely do you have a ritual
that you do before you take the stage
i do me and the guys usually huddle up
and say a little you know
inspirational quote you know happy wife
happy life on three you know
so uh no but we do we circle up like i
just have to like have a
like a shot of whiskey and then that's
kind of that's all i need
lastly besides your wife what are the
things in life do you consider
forever oh man that's a deep
question that's a deep question um i
don't know music i think
for me you know as something that it
will always be around you know
um always be wanting to write songs and
even if people
don't like him i guess i'll still be
doing it you know that would be sad but
i would still be playing guitar and
singing and writing stuff
and you know going outside i don't know
i mean i think that would be it music
for me